laure a été ma meilleure amie
je serai là toute ma vie
pour veiller sur ta fille lui si
c'est sur son père david
en fait je n'ai pas dis tu lui david
évident mais comme tu as appelé par le
chef et
tu énorme thème pas possible ça fait
longtemps
on sort j'ai un effort
à faire du bien il prend un peu de temps
pour moi
la charmante en haleine très jolie robe
c'est vrai
qu'on a été loin d'être la serveuse
david yen perd sa femme que tu pousses à
draguer c'était
j'ai bien vu que l'intéressé pas
en fait j'adore ton rouge à lèvres ça
très bien
au revoir tu couches avec david c'est ça
qu'est ce que tu racontes
ouais
bonjour madame
me dit rien à personne que ça reste
entre nous je sais pas
tu as rencontré quelques uns des femmes
très douces à me comprend sans me juger
balade à
ne pas passer à côté de ma vie car c'est
en moi
ça pourra pas durer david c'est une
folie
dernier revers
traiter